elon musk yesterday said that the u.s
government uh basically shouldn't
regulate the crypto market he was at the
uh i think a recoder code they might
have changed the name uh out in beverly
hills in la and he was asked on stage
what he thought about regulation in the
crypto market we do know that one elon
owns a material percent of bitcoin in
his net worth uh we also know that tesla
has purchased about a billion billion
and a half dollars worth of bitcoin
earlier this year they sold 10 percent
uh to test liquidity and then tesla also
has accepted bitcoin as payment in the
past he has two quotes here the first
one he says i wouldn't say that i'm a
massive cryptocurrency expert
i think there's some value in
cryptocurrency but i wouldn't say it's
the second coming of the messiah very
strong words from elon then he also said
quote it is not possible to i think
destroy crypto but it is possible for
governments to slow down its advancement
and so i think generally his point is
look you can't destroy it you could slow
it down but
there's a lot of things that we could
focus on regulating this space more than
it already is probably doesn't make as
much sense as some of the trade-offs so
what else you could do i appreciate him
saying that he's not an expert in the
space uh just speaks to like his
openness and what he's like really um
i don't think anyone was confused on
that
[Music]
yeah but you you've also you've said a
lot of times that bitcoin is actually in
the cryptocurrency space actually more
regulated than the traditional finance
base um can you expand on that so
well if you think about uh the reason
why
i say it
if i go tonight and i buy dinner right
me and john go uh to dinner and i have
dinners on you tonight sure and when i
pay for the meal i pay for the cost of
the meal let's say the meal is 50 bucks
right or we have inflation so it's a
hundred dollars then uh i pay sales tax
and if i buy it with dollars that's it
cost of the meal sales tax but if i buy
with bitcoin i pay the cost of the meal
i pay sales tax and i have to pay
capital gains on my bitcoin
not really uh conducive to using bitcoin
right so it's over regulated compared to
um using dollars on top of that in the
financial capital of the world in new
york city
it is harder to start a crypto company
than it is a traditional financial
company and so if i want to start let's
say a fintech business i go and i get
all the licenses that i need i get my uh
broker dealer license i do my kyc aml
get my money transmitter license all
that stuff and i get uh my business up
and running and i'm good to go if i want
to start a crypto company i have to do
all those same things money transmitter
broker dealer aml kyc etc then i have to
apply for a new separate license just to
operate a crypto company called a bit
license in new york and they've only
given out on a handful of them so it's
harder to start a crypto company than it
is a traditional financial company which
ends up meaning that the businesses are
more regulated in crypto than they are
in the legacy world
yeah i mean i also think it's important
to note that he's obviously financially
incentivized for it not to get regulated
in a negative way right so
tesla owns bitcoin uh i don't know if
they still allow customers to pay for
things in bitcoin but he personally owns
a lot of bitcoin i think he owns some
other uh crypto also but it's a material
part of his holdings uh investments wise
and i think he only holds
outside of his public holdings of the
companies he owns or the equity and the
companies that he owns uh bitcoin is his
largest holding so it's important to
recognize that he is incentivized for
the stuff to happen but he's right right
like we we always talk about it a lot of
times in the context of the united
states because that's where we live but
really when you look around the world
the country and the local governments
and the people that adopt these
technologies and create infrastructure
and rules and regulations to incentivize
people to come there and build on top of
these networks and advance the
innovation of these products are going
to be the ones that are the most
successful
and i think what he's saying is look
like
you're not going to stop a lot of this
stuff that's already happening now
they're decentralized networks there's
not much you can do outside of taxation
and a few other things so why wouldn't
you just innovate on top of that right
why wouldn't you allow a safe space for
people to come and build products
services etc
on these networks and on these protocols
and i think what we're going to see is
the governments that allow people to do
that and enable people to go do that are
going to benefit the most and the ones
that do it the earliest are going to
benefit the most and i think what elon
musk is saying is like hey look why
shouldn't the united states be
the leader in that space right if you
want to be the global superpower that
you always talk about you should be the
one that are allowing people to come and
innovate and do all the uh kind of
representing the ethos that your your
country uh says they represent all the
time
completely i don't think more regulation
uh necessarily deters innovation i think
it can kind of go both ways you do too
much regulation in a bad manner it can
definitely uh stop innovation but
innovation is gonna happen uh and like
he said you can't you're not gonna be
able to kill krypto you're not gonna be
able to kill bitcoin bitcoin right you
can over regulate it and make it super
annoying for people you can do what
china didn't try to ban it but people
are still gonna use it what's up guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today if we're
gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]